[Musique]
et c'est avec vous Mathilde Francou
bonsoir bonsoir Grégor et on débute avec
cette information sportive après plus
d'une semaine d'attente c'est enfin
parti pour les bateaux imoka de la
Transa jackvabre et oui après 9 jours
d'attente en raison des mauvaises
conditions climatiques lié aux tempêtes
kirane et Domingos les imoka ont enfin
pris le départ du Havre ce matin
direction la Martinique conséquence pour
cette catégorie le tracé a été réduit
pour cette 30e édition les bateaux
laisseront à tribord l'île de Santa
Maria parmi les 80 skippeerss de
yvelinois le rent bolitin Louis Burton
pour sa 7e transat fait équipe avec Davy
baudar sur bureau Vallé de son côté le
versaillais Éric bon pour sa 2uxe
participation est accompagné du skipper
Martin le pape sur standers One à 17h
bureauvallé pointé à la 4e position de
son côté standers One est 22e on suivra
bien sûr la traversée de nos skipers
yvlinois un coup de tennerur à présent
dans le monde du football ivlinois oui
c'est une information de nos confrères
du Parisien Laurent Perlade n'est plus
l'entraîneur du FC Versailles il a été
écarté de l'équipe en début de semaines
Laurent perlad était arrivé cet été sur
le banc versailla en remplacement du
Brésilien Chris conséquence sans doute
du bilan médiocre du club trois
victoires seulement en 12 matchs de
championnat de Nationale les Versaillais
sont actuellement 12e du classement ils
ont de plus été éliminé le weekend
dernier de la Coupe de France Laurent
Perlade est remplacé par son adjoint
Grégory vigal le FC Versailles
affrontera à nî au stade de jamboin pour
le compte de la 13e journée ce vendredi
on devrait pouvoir en 2024 mathil
circuler sur les autoroute en flux libre
la sanev société des autoroutes du Nord
et de l'Est de la France a détaillé le
calendrier cet après-midi qu'en est-il
dans les ivelines deux autoroutes sont
concernées grégoryi il s'agit de la 13
et de LA1 qui relie la région parisienne
à la Normandie parmi les 14 sites trois
sont dans le département le site de
Montesson le diffuseur N6 de chamb
boursie et le site de bûchelet
l'objectif supprimer les barrières de
péage pour ne plus marquer d'arrêt et
payer de façon dématérialisée depuis mai
2023 des équipements ont déjà été posés
sur les sites comme les fondations des
portiques des glissières et de marquage
au sol les sites de chamboursi et de
Montesson devrai recevoir leur portique
avant Noël 2023 interrogé sur l'impact
des travaux sur les automobilistes la
sanf se veut rassurante la société mise
sur la communication avant les
éventuelles fermetures des travau
principalement nocturnes mais aussi du
personnel pour aider à payer en décembre
2024 les 14 sites devraient être en
service on termine Mathilde avec une
information qui va intéresser les
amateurs de sport mais aussi les
demandeurs d'emploi Pôle Emploi Paris
2024 et Saint-Quentin en yelin organise
le 21 novembre une grande opération de
recrutement des milliers de postes sont
à pourvoir en vue des Jeux Olympiques
dans les domaines de l'hôtellerie la
restauration le tourisme mais aussi la
sécurité ou encore l'événementiel une
quarantaine d'entreprises se réuniront
au Vélodrome national de Saint-Quentin
en ieline plusieurs types de contrats
seront proposés accompagné de formation
ce rendez-vous est ouvert à tous et une
attente une attention particulière sera
accordée aux demandeurs d'emploi de
longue durée et aux personnes en
situation de handicap une préinscription
en ligne est obligatoire pour participer
à l'événement rendez-vous sur le site
internet 50 aniveline.fr merci Mathilde
et si vous aussi près de chez vous vous
êtes témoins d'une actualité qui vous
fait réagir dans les evvelines n'hésitez
pas à la partager sur les réseaux
sociaux en utilisant le hashtag 78 news